wenn sich manche läufer gegeneinander
abwägen und entscheiden wie sie weiter
ja und ich denke mit machen dass ich
falsch auch liefen gegen roh oder danken
will man sich einfach enthalten und sich
so wie sich und man nimmt das es aber
wenn jetzt mit wird machen und die
vorflut würde sterben würde könnten auch
gleich oder könnte mitglied
übersichtlich mit dem auseinandersetzen
da sie nie gemacht haben
liebe zum entscheider bis machen wie das
seminar also feigen unbeteiligt fühlen
so wie das ja solider lauf der dinge ich
finde wenn ihr im labor also das ist bei
sony
ich muss mich entscheide ja ich hab es
wird also eine innerliche euro
mitzutragen dauer ein bachelor oder mich
für diese situation zu entscheiden